Bogdanovic rebound Thaddeus Young
Oladipo squared sex hits his first field
goal
Oladipo his back against James it's a
running start puts up the break
knocks it down eight points nearly open
a quarter for Oladipo those were under
two minutes remaining
Oladipo fires another three that's good
Victor Oladipo with 11 points here on
the firk
Cory Joseph Wyatt's the crowd on the
depot's have a terrific defensive year
as well since the three knocks it down
rattles home that's his fourth
three-pointer he's got 16 you can
underrate their talent nice defense
Bogdanovich Scala sit with hood behind
him throws it back to Oladipo gathers
and banks at home that allowed him to be
ready for an expanded role fumble the
ball a little bit crowd wanted a double
dribble that's a guy we looking at as a
coach today but he was a heck of a
basketball player for a long time all
Addie Powell from downtown his fifth
three-pointer green over six from the
field
Oladipo running start pull up top of the
key it's good Victor Oladipo will a
couple of big buckets but in size
knocked away once again
not it Oladipo saponin sweat the
throwdown Wow Oladipo drives on love
scoots inside reverse Oh beautiful move
from Victor Oladipo he's got 29 pointing
showing for the Cavs the other paces the
mindset should be we didn't do anything
we didn't expect all the depo knocks it
down 32 points